10h15 - président m c'est quoi le secret
de ton flow dieu d'un quoi la question
c'est quoi le secret c'est quoi le
secret ton flotte gaudin mon flow de
godin d'accord avec la corée du nord
j'ai compris la section très bien c'est
quoi votre secret alors je sais pas je
pense que beaucoup de travail un peu de
culture connaître un peu les sons
beaucoup écouté de deux sont les
différents sons et en faire un cocktail
peut-être ce que j'essaie de faire comme
si tu avais gros sur comme tombe alors
dans la blague à part je sais ça se
travaille le flou c'est à dire donner de
délai de huit ans on m'a fait des
sensations de le fait d'accélérer la
vitesse le groupe s'est tu peux y mettre
un peu de leurs locaux dans le débit
voilà c'est quand même pas faire ce
premier pas qui va très vite c'est
eminem qui avait battu en route et ça
s'est vu ce qu'il a vraiment vrai nom
c'est julien lepers
deuxième question ne nous entend pas
monsieur deuxième deuxième question
n'est donc frère tu te trompes pas que
ça manque de boules de ouf dans tes
clips est vrai que contrairement aux
autres rappeurs tous avec vous avez
moins d'état moins de 2,9 dans vos clips
attendu ouais mais bon pour nous j'avais
j'aime bien vous voir je vous adore en
tant qu'artiste mais c'est vrai que
j'aime bien dans les clips de trois fois
voire des cucquois au moins c'est dit la
france n'avait pas non plus que c'est
pas c'est pas un manque de fabrique
somme ne correspond pas sap avec le la
musique que je fais je pense tout
simplement ceux dont elle est la
dernière des dernières est bien mais
parce que d'abord quand elle est dans la
question elle est vraiment en prendre
d'histoire géo à laideur new york et la
taille rares sinon oui alors que lui est
propre et dean salaire est un ingénieur
très très con cours mais non non mais
c'est bien des gens connaissent les
missions très sérieux j'ai compris en
plus t'as pas envie de lui mettre laser
mihas tarbes à joey starr justement ça
on va en parler
joey starr didier houi didier non pas du
tout moi je
j'aimerais l'aider il va venir très en
colère j'aimerais aller lui parler qui
s'allonge as un petit massage je vais me
détendre et qui m'explique le problème
mais qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce qui
se passe didier qu'est ce qui s'est
passé par le moins dix mois ce qui va
pas forcément je respecte son parcours
je respecte ce bonhomme maintenant mais
ça le jour où tu t'allonger avec lui
d'ailleurs d'envoi quivrin et vous en
parlez vous vous dites que ça a été
important pour vous ntn iam également
[Musique]